you all know I call things as I see them
and right now it's time to call the
virus situation as I see it idiots and
bad people are destroying our ability to
curb this virus as soon as possible
their behavior is putting people at risk
and it will cause people to die
unnecessarily people who didn't need to
die now I'm not just talking about the
people in our government I'm also
talking about just regular old people
you might remember old I just mean
regular people not elderly I did a story
back in February of last year about 13
months ago called it's time to admit
that many Americans are stupid and
clearly this struck a nerve it got more
than 600,000 views oh very positive
reaction more than 16,000 likes but a
lot of people didn't like it a lot of
people felt that it was an attack on
them to some degree or on on people who
dis lacked education and this is not
what we are talking about we have never
had a clearer case of bad and dumb
people will be the death of us then what
is happening now in the era of
coronavirus coronavirus has exposed the
deficits in our systems the deficits in
our healthcare system in our economy in
our presidents capacity to deal with a
crisis a total lack of capacity that is
but we're also hurting because of bad
and dumb people and I'm going to go
through some examples with you today
of course the context being to stop the
spread of the virus
absent functioning antivirals a vaccine
antibody treatments all of which are
under development it's gonna be a while
we need to reduce exposure and
transmission stop gathering in large
groups work from home stay away from
other people all this stuff many states
are realizing it's shutting down bars
and restaurants and gatherings even as
large as 25 people look at just a
sampling of what happened over the
weekend this is just a handful of
examples there are hundreds or thousands
of these Oklahoma Republican Governor
Kevin's spit posted a tweet of himself
out with his kids in a very crowded
restaurant sing eating with my kids and
all my fellow Oklahomans at the
collective OKC ate
pack tonight this is the exact opposite
of what medical experts say we should do
and of course we live in a world where
one party has decided medical experts
are basically just people with opinions
which we can ignore if we don't like
them because it's just like saying I
think low taxes are good it's just an
opinion
our Republican governor here in
Massachusetts is taking this seriously
activating a system to get nurses from
out of state licensed in-state within 24
hours to keep up with demand saying
close schools work from home starting a
restaurant and bar closure other than
takeout and delivery starting tomorrow
and meanwhile the Oklahoma governor is
bragging about being at a packed
restaurant with his kids
is this weaponized ignorant or is this a
bad person you tell me governor
eventually deleted the tweet because of
the obvious blowback people are hoarding
people are hoarding food of all kinds
people are hoarding toilet paper this is
creating an artificial sword egde there
was no expectation that the supply chain
was actually going to be disrupted for
toilet paper nor that toilet paper usage
would actually go up but people are
going crazy and they're doing it with
food as well here's video of people
rolling around on the ground pushing
each other yelling at each other and
fighting for toilet paper at some
big-box store I don't even know where
this is doesn't matter it's happening
all over for toilet paper
[Music]
again this is all started by rumor about
a shortage people go fight for toilet
paper and they cause a shortage because
people are hoarding it if people just
kept buying toilet paper at their normal
rate using it at their normal rate there
would be no shortage there'd be no
scuffles for people pushing each other
in order to get grab toilet paper are
these stupid people or are they bad
people I don't know the answer more and
more in blue states people are staying
home st. Patrick's Day Parade here in
Boston cancelled if you're from the area
you know just how big of a deal that is
not everywhere though here's a girl at
some kind of Saint Patrick's Day street
party talking about well I'm 21 I'm
immunocompromised but I don't care
because I take supplements I have a
compromised immune system but I'm still
only 21 but I'm not even worried because
I just take supplements and like I
self-medicate so it's fine is this a
dumb person or is this a bad person for
lack of a better term South Korea has
tested large numbers of asymptomatic 22
29 year-olds and found that a whole
bunch of 20 to 29 year-olds who feel
fine have the virus and they are
spreading it all over if they do what
this girl is doing it has to stop here
is Republican congressman Devin Nunez
going on Trump brown-noser Maria
Bartiromo is program on Fox and saying
hey you know what this is a great time
to go out to a restaurant it's not that
busy you can get right in and get a
table and there's a lot of concerns with
the economy here because people are
scared to go out but I will just say one
of the things you can do if you're
healthy you and your family it's a great
time to just go out go to a local
restaurant likely you can get in get in
easily there's you know let's not hurt
the working people in this country that
are relying on wages and tips
keep their small business very
sympathetic run to the don't run to the
understated I don't run to the grocery
store and buy you know four thousand
dollars of food I don't go to your local
local pub very sympathetic to what's
going no pushback from Maria Bartiromo
should that be criminal what Devon Nunez
said I tweeted asking should this be
criminal a whole bunch of my Twitter
followers said yeah
what Devon Nunez is doing there should
be criminal and now Devon Nunez isn't
wrong to be concerned about the economy
the economy is in a freefall but the
problem is a systemic structural one the
solution isn't to now say well we have
to just keep going to bars and
restaurants what we need is a system of
paid sick leave so he can be less
concerned about the restaurant employees
not having disbanded the pandemic
response team having a functioning
healthcare system these are structural
problems that they don't get solved by
saying go at the individual level and
continue to engage in the behavior
that's spreading the disease if we are
going to have this level of both
stupidity and just straight-up disregard
for others we are in very very serious
trouble and as we see the partisan
divide Republicans have to a third as
likely to be worried about coronaviruses
Democrats to be taking action around
coronaviruses Democrats we are in a in a
situation that is only going to get
worse that's where the data is pointing
right now I have a really interesting
video to look at with you today we are
truly seeing the worst of what a
dishonest and incompetent administration
is capable of dr. Seema Verma was
interviewed by Fox News's Martha
McCallum now dr. Verma is the
administrator of the Centers for
Medicare and Medicaid Services in the
trump administration and part of the
coronavirus task force she went on Fox
News and was asked six times by martha
maccallum very specific questions about
the number of tests i see use and
ventilators available for coronavirus
okay Trump has been insisting for weeks
anyone who wants a test can get it can
get a test they can't that's not true
Trump has been saying people who are
flying into the country are being tested
no they're not they're sometimes just
having their temperature taken Trump
says there are more than enough tests
there are not Trump pretends like our
cases numbers are accurate because we're
testing so many people were not the
numbers aren't accurate we might have
half a million people currently infected
and I have to say this is not praise of
anything other than martha maccallum in
these five minutes okay it's not praise
of martha in general it's not praise of
fox news it's merely martha maccallum
realized she was being snowed she does a
good job of exposing this Trump robot
who can't stop lying and can't answer a
single question so I'm gonna play for
you a bunch of questions which
essentially ask the same thing what is
the number of actual tests available
what about the icy use what about the
ventilators and you will notice how
every single time dr. Seema Verma just
talks about something different and
martha maccallum tries to bring her back
and dr. Verma just again answers about
something else when even Fox News hosts
have to expose a trump bot for obvious
lies and deception you know they're
being more deceptive and dishonest than
usual let's get right into it
my pleasure how are we doing on these
tests I remember last week I believe
Alex a czar the HHS secretary said that
there would be millions of them out
there by the end of the week how's that
happened you know our focus is on making
sure that people that need tests can get
tests and so one of the things that's
already available is that at every
public health laboratory across the
nation these tests are available what
we're working on now is to increase the
capacity in the private healthcare
system because most of us when we go get
tests we don't go to a public health lab
you're used to going to your doctor's
office they order the tests and that
usually is handled through our private
health care system and so we've been
working with the private system to
essentially ramp up so we can make sure
that those tests are available our focus
is on making sure people who need the
tests get it so we're working on
capacity at private versus public it's
not an answer so martha maccallum tries
again
you promised millions of tests by now
and we don't have them right doc so is
it true that there are millions of those
it's now almost the end of the week so
has that mark been met that we heard
about from secretary is there because I
was at a doctor for something else the
other morning and asked and they said
you know we can't get him we've been
calling we called the state we called
here we can't we can't get our hands on
them and then I heard it from another
doctor earlier today with the same story
with a patient that she wanted to test
and she tried to get a test for that
patient and was unable to do so well
today one of the things that we did dr.
Hahn and I hosted a call with over 1600
representatives from hospitals to work
with them around how they can do the
testing inside their Hospital
laboratories the other thing that we're
focused on is for pairing the entire
healthcare system some of the
conversations that we've been having
with hospitals is making sure that they
have again no answer question is you
promised millions of tests my doctor
says they have none she answers we'll
listen we've been having phone calls
with hospital reps about testing and
hospitals we've issued guidance no tests
no answer and martha maccallum is
starting to get irritated she
filibustered there for more than a
minute eventually again martha maccallum
manages to get a word in and asks
another time and this time she says well
we have ICU shortages we have ventilator
shortages we have shortages of equipment
to do tests okay but in terms of actual
equipment we heard Bernie Sanders today
for one coming out and saying that
there's a major shortage of ICU
units we've heard that there's a
shortage of ventilators even swabs and
equipment for the actual tests what's
being done about that and how concerned
are you that when when we these numbers
do start to rise which doctor flowey has
told us to expect that there'll be
enough ICU units enough ventilators to
help the people who do get sick in this
country well that's why we have an
emergency prepared system you know we
were used to dealing with disasters if
we look at some of the disasters that
have happened around hurricanes in
Puerto Rico in Florida there is a system
in place to make sure that folks that
are on the front lines have the
equipment and the supplies that they
need are you saying that we do have
CMS's to have rapid dialogue with health
care providers so we're meeting with
providers well we have a system but the
question was about equipment oh but
there's no answer to that we have a
system we have meetings we have guidance
they have plenty of dialogue and
guidance clearly but what about the
equipment more filibustering about tests
and equipment Martha comes back in again
and this time dr. Seema won't even let
her ask again just talking over martha
maccallum the needs that they have yeah
thing that we've really more talent
though there being enough sure that
people understand hey before you go into
your doctor's office you can call your
doctor on the phone and have a
discussion with them and they can tell
you whether you need to come in or not
and that's really important because we
don't want to have people hunters travel
unnecessarily if they're not feeling
well no and if they if they come into a
health care facility they could also be
putting others at risk
Martha tried to ask again and the doctor
just said you know call your doctor have
a discussion eventually martha maccallum
gets to ask one more time and this one
is just nuts dr. Verma goes directly
into saying Trump has been bold and
decisive and check out the look on
martha maccallum face she can't believe
it it's a smirk of disgust as the last
big lie is told and dr. Verma knew it
was a five-minute interview and this was
the last 30 seconds praise Trump and
avoid answering the question I'm sure
that that providers can use tell
telehealth and telemedicine right to
serve their patient at that point here
quite quite a bit and I think it's a
very important point to make but before
I let you go I want to ask you one more
time are there gonna be people in this
country who don't get a ventilator if
they need one are you concerned that the
actual physical equipment that is needed
to serve the people who will get sick is
out there can you reassure everyone
tonight that there is not a shortage of
ventilators or ICU units and that's why
the president has taken such a bold and
decisive action right we're not waiting
for this to get worse we're not waiting
for this to be a crisis in our health
care systems and that's why the
mitigation strategies that he announced
last night limiting travel from Europe
not allowing that you know we've given
travel advisories on cruise ships that's
why we're taking
all in this action because we don't want
to put stress on the healthcare system
okay that's not a direct answer to the
question but it sounds like a hope that
there won't be enough sick people and we
won't run that one right out ventilators
because we have mitigated and we
certainly hope that we certainly hope
that's the case
guys this was five minutes martha
maccallum asked five times tried to ask
six times was only able to ask five
times about tests and ventilators and
ICUs and there was not a single factual
answer from this Trump bot who just it's
almost like her software malfunction
then she just kept repeating the answers
to a different she was working off of a
script for a different interview it
didn't matter she loaded up that script
and read it for this interview and it's
dishonest it's disgusting and you know
this is nothing other than saying at
least here Martha McCallum kept asking
and said those aren't really answers to
my questions what else can we do do
they're just not going to be straight
with us hey this is pretty funny and
also kind of sad over the last few days
as we've seen the virus become more and
more of a crisis in the US and around
the world the Trump administration and
many Republicans and many media outlets
right-wing media outlets immediately
called for the types of programs that
they often oppose that they sometimes
even call socialism and this includes
simply sending people cash right sending
people checks that they can deposit
suspending foreclosures on mortgages
discussions about what do we do about
rent payments what do we do about people
who work for tips all of this stuff
where the answer is we've got to just
start sending people money or telling
them hold on to the money don't don't
send it to us or to wherever it is that
the money might be due um now it's
correct for this to be done this has to
be done as I've made clear before things
that we previously can't afford now we
all of a sudden can't afford not to and
we need to as soon as possible do it and
start sending the money around that
that's fine I get that the situation is
changing and people are realizing we
actually can't afford this stuff and we
need to do it it just so happens though
that
any of the people that are basically now
talking about the type of program that
2020 Democratic presidential candidate
Andrew yang suggested he called that
universal basic income a lot of those
people were laughing at Andrew yang when
he was proposing it now I want to be
really clear okay Andrew yang talked
about $1,000 a month to everybody as a
permanent program the discussion now is
not that okay it's you know one time or
two payments of a thousand bucks each
$2,000 one-time payment somebody's
proposing 3,000 somebody's proposing
6,000 depends who you talk to to call
the emergency cash that's being proposed
now universal basic income would be
inaccurate they're not the same thing
but when you hear Republican Mitt Romney
saying we should give everybody a
thousand bucks right away it obviously
brings back memories from just months
ago when Andrew yang was saying give
people a thousand dollars a month so I
have a hilarious clip from Fox News
where host Dana Perino glitches when
Juan Williams the token supposedly fost
he's a pretty centrist guy on Fox News
he says isn't this what Andrew yang was
talking about and you all called it
socialism and Dana Perino sort of
glitches and then she just says no it's
very funny because he rightly points out
you all made fun of Andrew yang for
talking about just giving people money
to stimulate the economy and to improve
people's circumstances when he proposed
it and now you all are proposing it
admittedly on a different basis and with
a different time frame check it out for
the health of people then of course we
have to do everything to help for their
economic health on the other side work
what we make in front of this though
when Andrew yang suggested something
like it was socialism know what no when
he was saying send $1,000 there there
are people who think that universal
basic income is actually a pretty good
idea I don't think of it as necessary
socialism especially if you look at it
that in Alaska how they give back money
but there'll be plenty of time to figure
it out but to Dickens point $1,000 for
people who relate that's if they're
gonna need more than that
I agree Greg all right you sort of hear
the record skip when he says it
of course this is what people were
saying to me on Twitter a couple days
ago
people are saying David this is nothing
like any of the things that are that
were proposed by Democrats this is
temporary stimulus this is not universal
basic income this is not meant to be
permanent I get it but look at the way
that Dana Perino adds you know maybe
universal basic income isn't really a
bad idea a lot of people think it is a
good idea and look at what Alaska does
Alaska sort of does it and it's not
considered socialism that's right Dana
that's what we've been saying it's not
really socialism but at the same time
think about it on a deeper level whether
you are for or against universal basic
income and of course recognizing
universal basic income if we did it it
wouldn't solve the circumstances that
led to such inequality in the first
place right the wealth disparities we
have aren't going to be solved by
sending people a thousand bucks a month
we've talked about that before it seems
everybody is now agreeing that universal
basic income isn't socialism but
hilariously the example Dana uses oil
profits in Alaska being redistributed as
a dividend to all Alaska residents that
is way closer to socialism than anything
Andrew yang has proposed because you are
socializing a portion of the profits
from the oil industry when you say
Alaska has oil revenue and even if
you're not involved merely because you
live in Alaska you will be entitled to a
portion of that revenue of that profit
that is socializing a piece of that
industry now again clearly a stimulus
package in an emergency is obviously not
social socialism it's also not universal
basic income but it has been remarkable
how instantly these pull yourself up by
your bootstraps right wingers have
changed their tune I tweeted yesterday
it's been really difficult over the last
week or two weeks to find anti-vaxxers
and to find libertarians that are still
touting their keep the government
completely out of it I know they exist
and I know
you know when I say that people will say
David look at this libertarian or that
one but by and large we are hearing very
little from the anti-vaccine wait for a
vaccine to be developed and rightly so
they should they should be shutting
their mouths and mostly they happen and
we've been hearing very little from the
the extreme libertarians who say the
government should have no role to play
here this is why we can't ever listen to
them none of their talking points are
actually a political philosophy it's a
combination of vapid talking points that
sort of sound okay in the moment to them
combined with posturing and there's not
really an underlying political
philosophy or that they stick to beyond
own the libs and justify post facto
whatever it is we think makes sense at
the time
now last thought on this and I don't
want to devote a lot of time to this
today historically when we have seen
socially conservative and economic
populist regimes they are pretty ugly
regimes I don't want to do that analysis
yet but something to think about is if
we see a lot of these socially
conservative movements like the American
evangelical right you know Fox News etc
if we see them actually adopt some
economic populism historically that's
been pretty dangerous and some of the
worst regimes in history have been
socially conservative and sort of
economic populist at least in the way
that's being discussed now that doesn't
mean anything in particular I'm not
playing any kind of doomsday scenario
out but think we'll deal with this more
next week check out as we see the
Republican Party in the in the context
of this crisis and pandemic become more
economically populist while remaining in
principle socially conservative do a
little research into some of the other
socially conservative economically
populist regimes of the last hundred and
fifty years there's some pretty ugly
stuff there and just something that
we're thinking about I've been reading
about and maybe I'll talk to you more
about next week let's take a quick break
remember if you are not following the
david pakman show on twitch you might be
missing live streams follow me at twitch
TV
david pakman the United States is slowly
shutting down
thanks to coronavirus we're seeing more
and more states do what the federal
government has been way too slow to
recommend as we continue to be led by
the blind and the incompetent day after
day after day
the dishonest blind and incompetent
trump administration I should add and
this is simply going to be the new
reality for a while and I know that it's
horrible it's horrible what's going on
but if we don't start doing these things
it's going to get much worse the stock
market and the economy will likely
suffer far more than what we've already
seen stocks down 12% intraday as we are
filming right now we're my prediction is
we could be down 40% from the peaks of a
few weeks ago by the time this is all
said and done although who can ever
predict the bottom but once again
although I hope it doesn't happen we
have to be responsible whatever the
consequences we have to do what your
state says if we want a shot at turning
this around and part of the reason why
we now are increasingly going to more
extreme measures is because the initial
reaction was so incompetent from day one
it'll go away on its own this is no big
deal we have no cases the United States
even with the little amount of testing
that we are doing are rapidly in get
heading in the direction of being one of
the countries with the most cases in the
world now of course we have a really
large population but remember we had
quote leaders telling us we would likely
see very few cases here dr. Anthony
foutch II who's the director of the
National Institute of Allergy and
Infectious Disease he now is saying
straight up cancel or postpone any event
with 50 or people with 50 or more people
for eight weeks eight weeks so as a
starting point that's a long time I get
it but understand that the way these
infection curves go every day that it
grows is another day on the tail end you
need for the decline without a vaccine
or treatments if you have ten days of
case growth before you turn it around
you need 10 days of declines to get back
to where we are today if you do
they slowing down case growth for 15
days you then need 15 days on the back
end before you get back to where we are
today meaning for every day we don't
deal with this we are actually losing
two days minimum not to mention the
exponentially disastrous effect on the
medical system as I see us become
overwhelmed as we lack ventilators so
this will add up quickly today is day 14
in the United States of that steady case
growth imagine where we will be in
another 14 days if we don't turn it
around so in that context states are
starting to shut down
the federal government is is not doing
what they need to do here
they have been far too slow they have
been far too dishonest they're just
making things up whole cloth which I
will talk to you about momentarily so
Ohio is shutting down bars and
restaurants period now remember some
places may be ignoring the decrees at
their peril and it's true that there are
places which will say shut down and
people won't do it and local police are
not going to be able to necessarily
enforce every single bar arrest or not
following the rules it requires people
doing it it requires restaurants doing
it Illinois has ordered bars and
restaurants to close starting tonight
until March 30th that's a couple weeks
almost here in Massachusetts governor
Charlie Baker says all gatherings of
more than 25 people are banned
restaurants can be takeout only until
April 6th at minimum and possibly all
the way until April 17th some
conflicting reports about the exact
dates schools are closed things are
closing down California Governor Gavin
Newsom says California will be closing
bars nightclubs and wineries and that
everyone aged 65 and over should be self
isolating do not go out in public
Washington State is shutting down
restaurants bars entertainment and
recreational facilities restaurants will
be allowed to do takeout and delivery
there are people who still say you know
there aren't that many cases we have 340
million people and we have 3500 cases as
of right now number one understand that
we don't have 3500 cases by some
estimates we likely have between 1 and
500,000 cases we are just not testing
we're not testing we don't know how many
cases we have there are people who will
say this this is simply going too far
when you understand the math of viral
contagion you realize you have to do it
because it's too late because otherwise
it's too late it needs to feel like it's
too early because otherwise you're going
to be behind the curve and look at what
happened in Italy it's a tragedy what's
happening in Italy they did too much too
slowly and now they have more active
cases than China despite having a
population that's 96 percent smaller
than China's think about that and that's
because of delays every day matters
you've got to turn the corner on the new
case number meaning you need to change
the the inflection of the curve from
more new cases each day to fewer new
cases each day when you look at new
cases in the United States it's up every
day this is the time to shut it down
because otherwise in 10 days the US
could look like Italy if this comes to
your state and it likely will at the
rate that we're going be part of the
solution don't be part of the problem
and by the way don't horde okay
the hoarding situations getting very bad
there was no toilet paper shortage
expected rumors swirled that there would
be a shortage think about why would all
of a sudden there be a shortage doesn't
actually make sense people buying all
the toilet paper they see creates an
artificial shortage and you have tragic
stories of elderly couples driving
around all over the place not feeling
well in many cases looking for a roll of
toilet paper because you have people and
I'll play videos momentarily people
fighting it's like Black Friday looking
for the cheap TV / toilet paper I went
to my local a couple local grocery
stores all all yogurt was gone all eggs
were gone
all meat was gone frozen vegetables
frozen from all gone fresh produce by
the way plenty of people I guess
completely ignoring that at this point
don't horde get you know build up a
strategic supply of a couple of weeks of
food which most of us should have anyway
- a couple weeks is reasonable and
non-perishables and understand that you
will make the problem worse it's really
really bad what's going on this next
story has absolutely exploded and it's
as detailed as it is disgusting as we're
discussing today a whole bunch of
companies are working on corona virus
vaccines that's a good thing one of the
companies is a German medical company
named cure vac there are now widespread
reports with corroboration that Donald
Trump offered a billion dollars to this
company to secure the vaccine for the
United States only now the reaction from
Trumpets was totally predictable first
they denied it was true fake news fake
news fake news
oh it's been confirmed by German
officials and authorities well
they said good for Trump he's watching
out for us
America first which is exactly what you
would imagine a trumpet would say about
this so let's go through the details
Trump was interested in buying this
future of possible vaccine for the
United States for a billion dollars this
became known inside of Germany to the
point that the German government was
almost negotiating against Trump
offering money to the company so that
the vaccine would stay in Germany and be
available to everyone as it should be if
and when it is ready to go
Germans were understandably outraged the
world is understandably outraged Trump
wanted to get the vaccine here and only
here somehow
to help him politically that's what this
is about that's what Donald Trump was
trying to do
now of course US officials can't deny
the story because it's been corroborated
so widely what they're saying is it's
been misreported for example US
officials are saying we're talking to
lots of companies who are working on
vaccines and we can offer money to them
to help them of course that's not what
this what this is and any solution that
is found they say should be shared with
the world what they're not saying is
would it be shared with the whole world
at the same time
or would the United States get at first
the giving Trump the opportunity to
announce I got us the vaccine Americans
are getting vaccinated before anybody
else now adding to the intrigue here
last week this company cure vac weirdly
announced they were changing CEOs this
was unusual CEO Daniel Minh akela was
replaced by Ingmar hora just weeks after
men akela met with Donald Trump the
hypothesis is and again this part is
more speculative the hypothesis is that
men akela may actually have been willing
to accept the billion dollars from Trump
to give the vaccine only or at least
first to the United States the board and
stockholders of Kure vac caught wind of
it fired the guy put in a different CEO
and said very clearly if we are
successful in developing a vaccine it
should help and protect the entire world
the German Health Minister spon said
that a takeover of cure back by the
Trump administration is quote off the
table that cure vac will only develop a
vaccine for the whole world not for
individual countries look at where the
world is today Donald Trump offering
cash to give him the vaccine to let him
get the benefit and of course after
denying that this happened his
supporters predictably started saying
hey this is good
Trump's President of the United States
Trump is not president of Italy Trump is
not president of Germany his first
priority should be get us the vaccine
but of course this is as immoral as it
is stupid the disease didn't start in
the u.s. yet we are now increasingly
ravaged by it vaccinating only Americans
wouldn't help since no vaccine is 100%
effective not everyone would get the
vaccine and the disease would simply
keep spreading if only Americans were
vaccinated this is aside from this being
utterly disgusting it's also very very
short-sighted this is that that's sort
of dumb America first mentality that's
not only immoral but it's also ad otic
in this case and as I read this I
realized you know if Trump wasn't born
to a rich family instead of trying to
buy a vaccine for a billion bucks from
Germany he'd be the guy buying the hand
sanitizer in order to start price
gouging by then selling it at 30 or 40
bucks a pop understand that Germans are
shocked and appalled by this people in
Germany can't understand how is Trump
even a person that exists in the world
never mind how is he President of the
United States and sadly these low
information trumpets who see him as
unable to do any wrong say love it
go Trump make America great again keep
America great again
it's a nightmare hellscape of
embarrassment made worse every day
and just if to put a final point on this
imagine for a second the reverse
situation imagine a pandemic was
spreading all over the world and it
turned out that a US company had a
vaccine ready to go and imagine that the
US company sold rights to the vaccine to
I don't know
Italy or Germany or France or China or
Russia or whoever and maybe later they'd
make it available to Americans the same
people who are saying don't regulate
businesses and what a good job Trump is
doing trying to get us the vaccine would
be saying take over that business put
the executives in prison it is a
disgusting double standard it's truly a
stunning story and my guess is over the
next few days we'll learn a lot more
about the details make sure you're
following me on Twitter for all the
latest kovat 19 updates a lot is
happening on my Twitter account at D
Pakman we'll take a quick break and be
back right after this it's Donald Trump
lying about having been tested for
coronavirus and testing negative now I'm
not suggesting Trump didn't test
negative although it wouldn't surprise
me that if Trump had tested positive
they simply wouldn't tell us but the
timing and especially Donald Trump's
very weird answer yesterday when he was
asked about what it was like to be
tested it all sounds very strange and I
don't know that Donald Trump was
actually tested so let's go through it
first starting with the question
yesterday during Trump's coronavirus
press conference Trump
first answer about the timing and
results of his test you had your own a
virus test Friday night though the White
House doctor's office put out a
statement around midnight Friday saying
that no test was indicated so when
exactly was your test administered well
I had my test I was late Friday night
and the reason I did it was because the
I had no symptoms whatsoever so the
doctor said you have no symptoms so we
don't see any reason but when I did the
press conference and part everybody was
going crazy did you do the test did you
do the test so very late on Friday night
I did the test and he may have put out
or the doctor may have put out something
at a I don't know what time the letter
went out maybe it was put up by somebody
else but the results came back I believe
the following day and we tested negative
question positive why not doctor's
office wasn't indicated implying that
you hadn't had one when in fact you had
well I told them that and I went totally
by what they said the doctors more than
one they said you don't have any of the
symptoms they checked what you're
supposed to check and that I didn't have
symptoms but I did it I did a test late
on Friday night and it came back
probably 24 hours later or something
they sent it to the labs came back so
understand the timeline that Trump is
suggesting here combined with what we
know Friday at 3:30 Trump was asked
during his press conference about being
tested and he said I have no symptoms I
don't need to be tested but maybe
someday I will be Friday evening
the White House said Trump doesn't need
to be tested but then Trump now claims
that late on Friday he was tested for
coronavirus if the White House puts out
a statement saying nobody worried Trump
doesn't even need testing why would he
have been tested basically at the exact
same time that the White House was
putting out that statement and then
Trump claims that Saturday evening so
fewer than 24 hours from when he was
supposedly tested he got a negative test
result for a corona virus so the
question is a good one
if at 3:00 p.m. you said no symptoms no
need for a test if at night a doctor
said no symptoms no need for a test
why were you immediately tested and then
there's also the question of tests are
taking longer than 20 hours or 18 hours
now of course maybe when it's the
president they fast-track it
we don't know but they said that they
are hopeful someday we will get to 24
hour turnaround on tests we're not there
yet at this point in time if the test
was done very late Friday as Trump says
and then early on Saturday evening the
results were already announced that is
way less than the 48 to 72 hour range
that is typically the one that's also
weird
but then we get to the real whopper and
this is this is what Fermi suggested
this guy's not been tested Trump was
asked about the test and the test
requires a swab to be inserted pretty
deeply into the nose to get to the
throat it's not comfortable
most people gag tear up Koff etc which
is why the people doing the tests have
to be in full medical protective gear
and Trump responds in a way where it
doesn't seem like he knows how the test
is done and so he says something very
vague to avoid saying something that is
known to be untrue about the test itself
check it out and let me know what you
think nah not something I want to do
every day I can tell you that it's a you
know it's a little bit of a it's a
little bit of good doctors in the White
House but it's a test it's a test it's a
medical test nothing Pleasant about it
it's a test it's a medical test and I
wouldn't you know recommend it's not
something I would want to do again does
this sound to anybody else like a
completely fabricated story that he made
up completely on the spot so let me know
what you think do you think Trump is
lying about having been tested at all do
you think Trump is lying about the
negative result if you said to me is the
lie about the result or is the lie about
being tested
I think the lies about being tested not
not not about the result although I do
think they would likely lie about the
result as well let me know what you
think I don't know